[Música]
se eu dissesse que eu tenho apenas 18
minutos para sugerir uma teoria que
poderia solucionar a maioria dos nossos
problemas é cresci
infelizmente como uma criança bem doente
com inúmeros problemas de saúde
o que me levou a ser obeso
eu também era bem sedentário vivia com
uma dieta bem industrializada muita
gente food produtos de origem animal
levando a uma baixa performance física e
mental ao longo da vida sempre é
conturbado após meus pilotos alergias
problemas gastrointestinais e isso me
fez aos 22 anos estar diabético para
fazer duas cirurgias e cansado de tentar
o modelo usual em voga
acabei buscando soluções para os meus
problemas
infelizmente esbarrei com que era
chamado de depois de tentar todo tipo de
tratamento usual de bairro que era
chamado de a ciência da saúde eo
crudivorismo vegano
foi a melhor coisa que aconteceu na
minha vida eu não consigo ter palavras
para descrever o bem estar
os benefícios físicos e mentais que eu
vivenciei ao longo desses últimos 11
anos de caminhada já que são a 11 anos
que um vivo primariamente de frutas e
vegetais e uma pequena quantidade de
oleaginosas cruz
já pratiquei de junho até mais é 24 dias
só de água é pra falar a verdade acabei
de quebrar um jejum de três dias para
uma maior e melhor funcionamento
neurológico
nessa palestra então me deu o melhor
desempenho que eu podia imaginar físico
melhor desempenho
eu podia imaginar mental eu não sou uma
pessoa espiritualista mais uma conexão
com todo o mundo uma empatia que é
incapaz de ser descrita foi é
indescritível é como você acordar todo
dia como uma criança feliz alegre estar
sempre disposto sentir seu corpo mas
rejuvenescido comer quilos de comida e
se manter magra e se manter sempre
saudável já que há 11 anos
eu não só não queimou minha comida e não
tem panelas não têm fogões
mas eu não tenho nem um espirro uma dor
de garganta e bom toda teoria nova é
geralmente ostracizada nós temos
inúmeros grande número de grandes
teorias que foram na verdade vistas como
um absurdo
darwin e galileu e copérnico entre
outros levou 50 100 anos para a
comunidade científica ver que era algo
correto plausível
aí eu te pergunto você quer esperar 50
há seis anos para simplesmente perceber
que comer comida da horta comida dá a
ver como ela aparece na natureza é muito
melhor do que comida industrializada
processada ou quem manda
então tudo começa com um mito da era
dourada o que nossa civilização cristã
sugere como o paraíso jardim do éden
já para os gregos era uma época perfeita
onde seres humanos viviam de frutas e
vegetais em um homem manchava a boca com
o sangue dos animais morreu no sono aos
120 anos sem doenças então ventos
gélidos que tiraram seres humanos no
paraíso de acordo com a ael esse mito e
assim ver o titã do fogo prometheus
e de um fogo os seres humanos ea carne e
com isso ocorreu a queda do homem
nós facilmente conseguimos correlacionar
com os dados da geologia que mostra que
ocorreu uma era glacial em torno de 100
mil anos atrás
e essa era glacial acabou há 13 mil anos
começando com que nós chamamos de um
período neolítico foi a introdução da
agricultura de grãos ea domesticação de
animais ou seja mudamos de uma natureza
nome de arbórea frugal por uma natureza
estacionária baseada em grãos e pedaços
de animais mortos e suas secreções
mamários
então tudo indica temos dados
antropológicos para sugerir serviço mãe
provar seres humanos habitam a terra em
torno de 8 milhões de anos
o cozimento é algo extremamente recente
na nossa dieta a introdução de grãos e
pedaços de animais mortos cada vez mais
freqüente é muito mais uma recente
nós temos sabemos que existem em torno
de 700 mil espécies no planeta e nenhuma
delas cozinha apenas o ser humano e é o
único que sofre de doenças crônico
degenerativas
então nós vamos para a antropologia o
doutor alan ball que ao estudar
parâmetros dentários de fósseis de seres
humanos até o período dos meninos até um
período muito recente mostra marcas de
animais comedores de frutas
nós temos o doutor hugo é o do francês
hipótese tinha publicado uma pesquisa
depois de dez anos
ao estudar gatos e mostrar que quanto
mais ele cozinhava suas comidas e mais
ele introduzir alimentos refinados mais
eles te sineira vão apresentando todo
tipo de problema crônico ou agudo de
seres humanos vivenciam ele foi o pai da
ep genética mostrando que o que a gente
faz hoje tem efeitos trânsito
nacionais para as próximas gerações e os
gatos ao após a terceira geração se
tornavam tão doente tão fracos que não
conseguiu mais de procriar e morrinho
nós temos então um caminho mallard um
médico que provou a mais de 100 anos que
simplesmente por cozinhar uma batata 420
substâncias tóxicas se formavam nela
nós temos hoje em dia falamos tanto não
há nada nos produtos da reação de málaga
na faculdade de nutrição
mas todo mundo esquece e queimar seu
alimento formando essas substâncias são
correlacionados a todo tipo de doença
crônica degenerativa a lei de serem
cancerígenos mutagénicos genotóxicos
citotóxicos teratogênicas pró
inflamatórias
nós temos o que é chamado de leucocitose
digestiva
foucault colo em 1930 médico ganhar um
prêmio nobel por mostrar que o aumento
nos leucócitos as células de defesa do
organismo que ocorre quando se ingere
não era algo fisiológico mais patológico
que ocorria simplesmente com comida
cozida comida crua não a causar esse
efeito o que leva nos a concluir o que
levou ele é concluir que comida cozida
para o organismo era algo patológico
temos do outro s tom price que mostrou
ao mundo alguns comparar seus pacientes
do mundo ocidental com seus pacientes do
mundo primitivo que já que ele viajou
para a cidade primitivos civilizações
primitivas durante dez anos demonstrou
que essas pessoas sem aos 80 anos sem
nunca ter visto é a ciência médica atual
ou nada da tecnologia moderna não tinha
um cariz um a um corpo perfeito da
edição perfeita e eram muito mais
produtivos
nós temos
é é seu hobby é mércio um outro médico
foi pago pela corte britânica para
apagar a passar de 10 anos e é com os
usa uma civilização no norte do
paquistão que viverá primariamente de
comida crua de frutas e vegetais e
alegou ser extremamente impressionante à
saúde dessa espécie que chegava e foi
comprar foi chamado até mesmo de
xangri-lá por parar o envelhecimento
onde sugere que seus homens fazem filhos
aos 100 anos de idade
nós temos o que é chamado gerir smo de a
lei das similaridades ou seja usamos
anatomia comparada e taxonomia pra
mostrar que animais similares comem de
forma similar ou seja é como se a
natureza tivesse feito cada espécie
embutida com ferramentas para se
alimentar
anatomia fisiologia bioquímica são
ferramentas que cada animal tem para
animais carnívoros os reais carne ovos
comem o animal cru fresco abatendo ele
na hora secretando grandes quantidades
de ácidos produzir proteínas não
secretando amilase enzima para adquirir
carboidratos conseguindo alcançar 120
quilômetros impondo até duas toneladas
na mandíbula e se você realmente acha
que você foi feito para o consumo de
carne à button animal cru com as suas
mãos como sem sal sem cozinhar e depois
a gente depois me conta
então nós temos animais herbívoros que
literalmente secretam enzimas para
digerir a gama a seu lado visitante rian
celulose possui até mesmo quatro
estômago us porque são ruminantes nós
temos os grandes livros os animais
a definição da biologia dos animais que
vêm primariamente para o consumo de
grãos possuem bicos pontiagudos
em coletar aqueles minúsculos grãos o
que o oeste possui empapuça onde eles
determinam os grãos ou seja o parceiro
como um grão cru não precisa cozinhar
nós temos porcos e javalis e outros
animais com focinhos que tem a
capacidade de células e de modais 100
vezes mais fortes dos seres humanos o
que permitiu saber tem batata debaixo do
solo oeste possuem patas pescava
secretam grande quantidade de amigos já
que eles como batata crua e
provavelmente como eles comem sem sal e
sem tempero e sem cozimento
eles sentem gosto no amido coisa que
animais frugívoros ou seja a definição
da biologia para os animais que vivem
primariamente de frutas e vegetais
a definição dos animais que conseguem
enxergar cores porque eles precisam
diferenciar frutas verdes madura
a definição dos animais conseguem sentir
o gosto doce que quase que exclusiva da
espécie dos primatas
por isso que seja uma manga por um gato
você joga uma manga para um animal se
jogam um pedaço salmão por seu gatinho
ele fica apaixonado
então nós temos visão no espectro de
todas as cores capacidade de sentir o
gosto doce polegares opostos o que
permite uma vida arbórea ea colheita das
frutas elas cabelo economicamente na
nossa mão
nós temos não bill sintetizamos vitamina
c como animais carnívoros o fazem
morremos escorbuto sem ela
então temos o criacionismo e
evolucionismo a maior parte das pessoas
sugerem não gosta é chamado de um
primata obviamente então
ou nós concordamos com darwin ou saímos
do hotel de adão e eva a genética mostra
que não compartilhamos 99 ponto 3 no
nosso material genético como os primatas
antropóides mais especificamente bombo
anatomia fisiologia bioquímica prata
idêntica os dados de epidemiologia que
mostra que a principal causa de morte do
mundo é o consumo insuficiente de frutas
temos a primatologia mostrando que a
alta ingestão de micronutrientes desses
primatas que vivem primariamente de
frutas e vegetais crus é
imensuravelmente maior do que as nossas
recomendações dietéticas diárias e por
isso eles são extremamente mais
saudáveis
nós temos a microbiota comparações dos
microrganismos que vivem dentro do
intestino dos nossos parentes mais
próximos que o chimpanzé pigmeu bonobo e
é a que mais ele é o que mais incluir
fruta em sua dieta e o que mais se
agrupa se é próximo aos seres humanos de
todos os meninos
nós temos as doenças cardiovasculares
que matou 38 por cento da população
mundial e nós sabemos que fazem
pesquisas e comparando pessoas indiretos
frugívoros indiretas veganos saudáveis
em dietas onívoros saudáveis tem como
ter uma dieta livre saudável e dietas
fugiu e sanções mais eficazes e melhorar
níveis de biomarcadores tudo que você
consegue mensurar o seu sangue é má e
começa a se tornar cada vez mais rápido
saudável com uma dieta de frutas e
vegetais nós temos análise do intestino
de primatas com humanos mostra que a
raça humana assim como os primatas
antropoidea uma raça fugiu não
especializada
o ibi matas que às vezes alguma pessoa
chama de ônibus na verdade menos de 3%
da sua dieta vende carne exames
bioquímicos e e vários e outros tipos de
exames mostrando de pessoas vivendo a de
frutas e vegetais há mais de dez anos
tenhamos até mesmo de glicemia perfeito
açúcar no sangue
dezembro é proteger e mia ou seja a
proteína no sangue do ano perfeito e
praticando exercícios físicos
perfeitamente é ter um exclusivo os
veganos comparados ao livros têm menor e
mc peso percentual de gordura menores
níveis de proteína c reativa o marcador
inflamatório e menores níveis de jeff um
hormônio relacionado ao câncer menores
níveis de vitamina d
aí temos ainda as doenças neuro
cognitivo e cinco reais
acionados aos toxinas do cozimento os
dados com os produtos da educação
avançada é consumo de produtos de origem
animal
nós temos ainda os animais mais
inteligentes da natureza são os que mais
consomem frutas e frutas e vegetais são
neuroprotetores nós ainda temos os
alimentos que influenciam no
comportamento nós sabemos que primatas
ao comer no pé plantas mais similares ao
sol a soja ficam mais agressivos
enquanto ele quando eles comem frutos
eles ficam menos agressivos e nós
sabemos que os bonobos da onde nós
saímos a ser de milhões de anos atrás
o a raça que nós divergimos vivem
primariamente frutos
então a solução que eu sugiro é a
fruticultura e educação nutricional ou
seja nós facilmente conseguimos acabar
com a fome já que árvores frutíferas
produzem muito mais do que as próprias
plantações de grãos que é mais eficiente
da agropecuária porque árvores crescem
em 3d ao invés de 2d como os campos de
grão mas já que ela está dando já cá a
10 metros de altura
nós temos saúde que nós sabemos que os
compostos bioativos dentro desses
alimentos protege contra câncer doenças
cardiovasculares diabetes
temos as questões do meio ambiente que
literalmente não árvore é o o o pulmão
do planeta ela protege e de inúmeras
formas o meio ambiente
nós ainda temos a ética animal que nós
sabemos que não precisa matar animais
pra simplesmente ser saudáveis
escravizavam estruturá los e ainda temos
a redução da produção de lixo de toxinas
ambientais já que a fruta vem embalada
ela já tem plástico nela então falando
nas palavras de hipócrates que a comida
seja mil de seu medicamento literalmente
já que a comida contém muitos nutrientes
que funcionam como medicamentos e pra
finalizar dando quase todos sofremos
juntos ao não sermos responsáveis como
jorge falou nós acabamos danificando o
planeta
em todo os animais seres humanos a
natureza
todas elas sofrem choram e se eu posso
terminar a palestra abstenham-se mortais
de poluírem seus corpos com a carne dos
animais existe há milho há maçãs que
forçam os galhos para baixo com seu peso
existem ruas nozes e vegetais
esta deve ser nossa alimentação citando
pitágoras então a paz é bioquímica não
queime seu alimento
ao ser saudável sua bioquímica muda
interfere no seu comportamento e isso
vai interferir no todo como você se
relaciona com você mesmo seus entes
queridos e o planeta nos animais
literalmente voltando ao paraíso bom
voltarmos a consumir frutas e vegetais
os alimentos da raça humana nós voltamos
ao paraíso interno externando anos esse
paraíso e voltamos a era dourada
finalizando libertação animal muito
obrigado
[Música]